nombre d'applications
[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous alors c'est vrai
que le pauvre il a rien demandé
il a filmé une scène bon qui est assez
curieuse un mine de rien on va montrer
la vidéo longue dans un instant
qu'est-ce que vous filmez au départ
andreas vous vous étiez vous trouviez la
vous habite à côté en fait c'est ça
ouais mais pas loin
ouais j'étais là je voyais qu'il y avait
un peu de tension entre ces deux
personnages je vais filmer
ouais au début non parce que c'était
drôle au début c'était vraiment drôle
ouais mais après dès que la tension a
commencé à monter j'ai pensé que ça
pouvait aller plus loin de du coup c'est
là que j'ai commencé à filmer d'accord
alors on va voir la vidéo dans son
intégralité
donc c'est une dame avec un jeune homme
et c'est vrai que la vidéo elle était
donc d'abord diffusée comme ça sur les
réseaux juste la fin voilà même si ça
n'explique rien je vous dis parce que ça
aurait pu être très grave est vraiment
la femme ait eu énormément de chance et
des bons réflexes ont regardé la vidéo
dans son intégralité
regarde pas droit chakib el hara
m
alors c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois qu'on
le revoit pousser cette dame on a
toujours peur c'est le contraire vous
avez tout filmé est ce que le garçon et
est parti après ou comme vous le voyez
il est parti il y avait une voiture
derrière moi il a pris la voiture et de
paris il est reparti et vous êtes allé
voir la dame après juste après ou pas du
tout non la dame trois secondes elles
étaient les témoins l art est monté les
escaliers elle allait très bien elle est
répartie agressive comme d'habitude à
elle comme c'était avant et elle allait
bien elle allait vraiment très bien vous
avez publié cette vidéo
ouais quelques minutes après une dizaine
de minutes après que vous avez vu que
vous avez vu le buzz que ça fait je me
suis même pas perçu c'était des potes
qui m'ont dit c'est toi qui avait filmé
la vidéo regarde ici twiter machin bfm
tv elle a relancé
c'est n'importe quoi il n'y a rien qui
s'est passé pour moi
pour moi c'est pas c'est assez choquant
regardez là le pêcheur points
mais comme moi j'étais présent il y
avait plein de monde dans cette place
c'est pourquoi ils se sont brouillés ou
pas du tout non du travail et où
visiblement il y avait là la dame était
censé lui rendre quelque chose
d'accord et donc du coup pendant
quelques minutes et lui la suivait très
calmement mais il a lâché pas ils disent
et il faut que tu m'aies raid on ne sait
pas quoi je sais pas encore de quoi il
s'agit
la dame l'a tapé plusieurs fois lui
donner des coups même sur les visages et
c'est quand même donné un coup sur le
visage qui j'ai dit oh là là ok qu'est
ce qu'elle fait là est apparemment lui à
un moment il a perdu la patience mais
lui il était au début il était calme et
je ne m'attendais pas du tout qu'elle
allait terminer comme ça vous sont pas
demandées lui ou elle un moment ce qui
c'est comme vous avez filmé lui vous a
pas dit il faut pas finir aux pneus ça
c'est une interprétation je pense que
lui il a regretté
mais je pense que lui voulait pas parce
qu'il aurait pu être plus agressif
avant je pense que il s'est rendu compte
qu'il a fait un acte qu'il fallait pas
du tout faire et donc du coup il est
parti j'ai pensé qu'il a regretté même
eu de la chance que ce soit pas plus
grave pour pour la dame ouais parce que
mais avec classe et encore une fois je
vous dis elle sert à rien fait vous
voyez dans la vidéo ça se voit il ya une
dame qui est là qui à côté d'elle
si on pouvait voir la fin de la vidéo
sont là parce que c'est vrai que c'est
heureusement elle sait rien fait et je
vous assure que trois secondes après
elle était déjà elle était déjà ici avec
les os extrêmement c'est ça elle remonte
à près avec une dame
oui alors la version de la faire gilles
verdez oui alors l'auteur des faits a
été interpellé dans le val d'oise
oui la dame victime s'est présentée aux
forces de l'ordre pour expliquer la
faire et d'après l'enquète qu'on a fait
avec bernard il s'agirait je mets un
conditionnel mais on en est sûr il
s'agirait en fait d'un rendez vous elle
a parlé elle au début d'un téléphone
j'avais un téléphone j'attendais un
appel etc
il s'agirait d'un rendez vous entre les
deux protagonistes pour une histoire de
consommation de drogue sans doute du
crack c'est à dire qu'il y avait une
livraison prévue c'était un rendez vous
si je puis dire commercial alors ça
n'excuse comme vous l'avez justement dit
absolument pas la violence de l'homme
qui tape la femme dans l'escalier mais
c'était un rendez vous qui a mal tourné
donc elle s'énerve auprès de
l'électronique visiblement il ya eu un
problème dans la livraison dans ce
qu'elle attendait dans ce qu'elle
voulait cendres c'est pas tous les
détails de la faire là mais c'est un
problème lire de la consommation de
drogue qui a mal tourné et lui est au
téléphone avec visiblement le
fournisseur dit ça se passe mal et il la
pousse ça n'excuse en rien le geste
attention à ce qu'il était au téléphone
avec
que sait qu'il a fait comprendre la
police il a dit à la dame maintenant
j'appelle la police et ça va voir etc
soir tu vas être en garde à vue et au
début de la vidéo il y à la dame qui dit
c'est toi qui va être en garde à vue
c'est ça ça sert un faux témoignage
ça on captait lui avant il a dit je suis
avec la police tu vas être un garde à
vue je pense que c'était un fait que ce
n'était pas vrai a été juste pour lui
mettre un peu de la reprise et ça je
crois c'est ça mais il sait ce qu'il a à
dire il a dit que lui allait appeler la
police alors très vite via le hashtag la
racaille tu qui a été entendue 8
popularisé à l'époque par le jour où
génération identitaire et qui est passé
en premier était ce week end donc c'est
vrai que la vidéo a énormément tourné
damien rieu candidats et rennes aux
élections départementales notamment un
commentaire marlène schiappa avec cette
vidéo la gauche va demander à ce qu'on
installe des ascenseurs à la place des
escaliers pour les bouches de métro afin
d'éviter ce type d'agression vous allez
voir ça me laffont toujours aucun
rapport avec l'immigration point
d'interrogation
voilà donc c'est vrai qu'il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup de trucs comme ça
géraldine oui c'est vrai que
l'exploitation politique est pleine de
démagogie moi j'en mets siam a
interpellé il m'a notifié dans un tweet
il m'a montré la vidéo donc tronquée
bien évidemment monsieur n'à pas on n'a
pas la vidéo dans son intégralité et il
m'a dit vous avez vu géraldine maillet
comme effectivement à la délinquance est
forcément à une tête de migrants a une
sale tête quoi donc voilà donc encore
une fois on est en plein délire donc la
fachosphère c'est ça n'excuse en rien
évidemment ce qu'a fait le monsieur est
éventuellement ce qu'a fait la fin la
dame en fait il s'agit juste de d'un
toxico avec fin avec un dealer en fait
c'est juste ça et parce que c'est connu
par de la chapelle pardon il s'agit pas
de stigmatiser une zone plutôt qu'une
autre
et c'est connu pour qui est beaucoup
beaucoup de trafic de crack une cocaïne
du pauvre aussi aussi bien porte de la
chapelle que porte de clignancourt et
là-dessus marlène schiappa tout de suite
par comme ça avec alors marleix a
l'habitude signaler les filles
l'admissible relayé par cette vidéo
harcèlement de rue puis sacré sportif à
préfecture de police pour que les
auteurs soient identifiés et interpellés
tout mon soutien à la victime hashtag ne
rien laisser laurent gbagbo on reproche
à un politique de réagir à une situation
qui le voient c'est quand même le rôle
du politique de dire ce qu'ils pensent
et d'interpeller mais ce qu'il faut pas
est ce que l'un dit wen à ce que les
politiciens ne réagissent pas un poil
trop faible c'est le problème qu'on a
c'est à dire qu'il voit un truc il se
jette le corps sur les réseaux sociaux
main et parfois il
dévoilé des réactions qui sont un peu
mais sont pas les bonnes déjà pour cette
dame
quand certains ont dit que c'était
peut-être une histoire de drogue tout le
monde a trouvé ça plutôt normal faut
rappeler quand on est des gens qui ont
une victime de et on est en situation
difficile et que rien n'excuse ce geste
d'une ultra violence qui aurait pu tuer
une personne ça c'est la situation le
hashtag la racaille tu ça veut pas dire
qu'on est raciste
la racaille c'est tous les gens qui
s'aiment a pas moi dans mon dans mon
esprit que la racaille c'est des gens
qui agissent comme ça qui deale de la
drogue etc
j'ai le droit d'avoir ma définition de
la racaille et pour moi ça veut pas dire
l'immigration et dire que c'est la
fachosphère qui récupère ça s'est un peu
trop facile réagir c'est normal la
liberté d'expression c'est pour tout le
monde qu'on soit de droite ou de gauche
ont dit encore ce qu'on veut et que vous
trouvez que ce genre de personnage qui
fait ça c'est de la racaille
oui c'est de la racaille maintenant
associé ça à son origine
ça c'est votre interprétation mais c'est
pas celle de tout le monde bah alors
c'est ce qui a tourné sur les réseaux
images horribles et bah ils ont quand
même montré la porte de la chapelle
honnêtement le problème dans cette vidéo
bon les causes des conséquences c'est de
ne pas dire peut-être mais comme une
agression d'un garçon sur une femme et
moi tout ça dommage qu'on ne soit pas
juste intéressé est interpellé par ça
plutôt que de montrer du doigt la porte
de la chapelle le fait que des gens de
couleur à gauche et à droite
et donc quand je dis récupération
effectivement parce qu'une fois plus on
s'intéresse pas à l'agression en elle
même mais à ce qu'est autour et ça c'est
en mer dans sa contrebasse que
'êtes-vous et lawrence ho st laurent
vous savez bien que dans les ans le
langage et vous le fais allez-y avec le
régime et non mais j'ai pas dis qu'avec
ces femmes avec cbrc nommé et je finis
et honnêtement on sait tous maintenant
la syntaxe la syntaxe de la droite et
l'extrême droite racaille on sait très
bien que ça dure et ça c'est pas la
saison passée pour ces gens-là sais
c'est pas c'est pas des blancs du 13e la
raquette c'est des gens de couleur david
lachapelle et si c'est ça ça me dérange
andrea est ce que un moment vous êtes
dit peut-être sécher fait une connerie
parce que là ça fait un buzz terrible ce
que j'ai peut-être pas ce que j'ai
déconné en mettant la vidéo sur les
réseaux pas du tout non non pas du tout
parce que
je répète la dame elle sait rien on fait
les gestes violents
c'est un conte d'amener on est d'accord
mais comme la dame et c'est rien fait je
les considère et après comme un candidat
mouiller comme j'en ai vu des milliers
et des milliers à paris et comme ça
arrive souvent les gestes et éclatants
mais ça aurait pu être très grave ce
week end
non moi ce qui me fâche c'est quand on
dit on aurait pu voir la vidéo en entier
mais ça a été coupée on s'en fout en
fait parce qu'à partir du moment où on
apprend que le mec c'est un dealer et
que la dame c'est une cliente bas dans
tous les cas la lamal est victime et
dans tous les cas c'est ce dealer qui la
rend agressif comme ça parce qu'elle est
justement accro à ce que lui lui vend
ses 7 6 ce truc là et véritable donc moi
qui me ce qui me fâche c'est
véritablement là on dit il lui est rien
arrivé à la dame comme ça ça aurait pu
être criminel mais où là il en parle
vraiment de la récupération politique
iliad marlène schiappa des lions qui
vous répond aux lanciers qui dit laurent
seillier a raison si elle nous fait une
réponse a donc marlène schiappa en
direct par sms
le flic le fait qu'elle ait poussé avant
ne justifiait pas que le type la pousse
dans le métro ont par ailleurs
absolument rien ne prouve qu'il soit
1,10 des réelles sa cliente à ce stade
pour l'instant on n'a pas d'informations
sur la sphère la police a arrêté
l'agresseur il ne l'aurait pas fait sans
raison si tous les témoins intervenez
comme andrea on pourrait mieux stopper
ces agressions il a bien fait voilà donc
ce qu'est le drame est la porte de la
salle oui désolé je vous commentez
l'émission en direct et bah merci
marlène schiappa pas c'est bien qu'on
ait des réponses en direct dans
l'émission dit un truc ici que ça se
passe oui bernard montiel
moi je suis comme vous il ya le mot
racaille laurent ce qui me choque
toujours quand on utilise ce mot il est
tellement mal est tellement va
l'utiliser que c'est toujours choquant
le mot racaille en revanche moyen de
choses qui me choque dans cette histoire
évidemment la violence quand cette femme
qui est inadmissible intolérable
quoi qu'il arrive qu'elles soient
victimes qu'elles apprennent du crack ou
pas on s'en fout c'est des gestes il est
indicible et la seconde chose qui me
choque c'est que personne ne l'a aidé
personne est intervenu tout le monde
regarde comme au spectacle et ça on
devient dans une société comme ça non
mais au départ on voit pas le danger je
suis désolé abattant les tombes elles
réaffirment regarderai si la sortie que
cinq secondes après l été elle est l art
est monté les escaliers elle par les
normands n'ont même
il ya des gens qui peuvent pour projets
qui peuvent dire je vois sur l'airé
d'autrui oui mais au lieu de filmer ce
qu'il n'aurait pas pu intervenir tout ça
parce que vous n'avez pas vu le danger
pourrait être actée mais voilà justement
qu'il y avait quelques le mec il n'a pas
avant on ne pouvait pas imaginer ses
gestes non mais je dois m'assurer que
parce qu'il au téléphone
s'il vous plaît il est au téléphone on
le voit il à eelv on va pas le
comportement agressif en u l'homme du
tout donc c'est vrai qu'au départ je
pense que voilà on se dit c'est une
embrouille et on a on s'attend pas du
tout ce qui la pousse et je vous le dis
pour lui et pour elle c'est vrai que là
ils ont eu énormément vraiment pas merci
andrien en tout cas d'avoir est avec
nous c'est vraiment la vidéo tableau des
flux